hi this is pressed Hawker can you solve
this deceptively difficult geometry
problem consider a rectangle R that's
made up of many smaller rectangles and
each of these small rectangles has
either an integer width or an integer
height or possibly both your job is to
prove the large rectangle R also has
this property that the large rectangle
also has either an integer width or an
integer height or possibly both give
this puzzle a try and when you're ready
keep watching the video for the solution
in the video description I provided a
link to 14 different ways that you can
solve this problem some which actually
involve some pretty advanced mathematics
in this video I'm going to present one
of the proofs which is the checkerboard
proof imagine a checkerboard
that's tiled with light and dark squares
alternately each tile has a height and
width of 1/2 that means two tiles
together will make an integer height or
an integer width now I'm going to draw
grid lines for that so the first step of
the proof is to show that a rectangle
with integer width covers equal areas of
light and dark squares so imagine a
rectangle that has an integer width
because it has integer width it's going
to line up perfectly with two of the
vertical lines because it has that you
can see that they're an equal number of
columns that start with the light square
as there are let's start with the dark
square so you can pair up the areas of
two columns together and you can see
that the entire rectangle is going to
cover an equal area of light and dark
squares furthermore this property is
going to hold even if you translate this
across you can see on the far left
there's a column which is kind of broken
starts with a dark square but that's
going to exactly compensate for the very
far right column that starts with a dark
Square and so you can pair up the
columns again and you're going to see
this rectangle
covers an equal amount of light and dark
squares and by extension this is going
to hold true even if I translate it
vertically the next step in the proof is
to show that a rectangle with integer
height
similarly covers equal areas of light in
dark squares it's a very similar proof a
rectangle with integer height is going
to line up exactly with two of the
horizontal lines so you can see that the
rows are going to have an equal number
that start with the light or a dark
square and therefore you can pair up the
areas and once again this is going to
hold true even if you translate this
rectangle up you're going to see it
covers an equal amount of light and dark
squares and even if you shift it to the
right you're going to see there's an
equal amount that this rectangle covers
of light and dark squares now for
completeness we need to show that the
rectangle without integer height or
integer width is not going to cover
equal areas of light or dark squares so
this is a little slightly more
complicated step of the proof but let me
try and explain it so let's say you have
a rectangle with has which has a width
of a and a height of B and neither are
integer lengths so if I place this
rectangle on a grid it's not going to
line up with any of the vertical or
horizontal lines where it will line up
is we're going to round the number a
down we'll call this the floor of a this
is rounding the number a down and it'll
line up by rounding the height B down to
the floor of B so we have placed this
rectangle and we divide it up into four
different sections on your checkerboard
now this lower left quadrant has a width
of floor of a and a height of floor of B
so that's an integer width and an
integer height so this region clearly
covers equal areas of light and dark
squares if we look at the region right
above that this region will have a width
that it's equal to the floor of a so
that's an integer with so this region
also covers equal amounts of light and
dark squares the third region has a
height that's equal to
Flor of B the floor of B is an integer
height so this region also covers equal
amounts of light and dark tours where we
run into trouble is that very final
quadrant this has neither an integer
with nor an integer height and there's
no way we're going to be able to cover
equal amounts of light and dark squares
so because this one little area doesn't
cover equal amounts of light and dark
squares this entire rectangle does not
cover equal amounts of light and dark
squares so what we proven is that a
rectangle covers equal areas of light
and dark scores if and only if at least
one side is an integer length so let's
put all that together here's a
checkerboard and we want to prove
something about our original rectangle R
so we don't know that this rectangle is
going to line up exactly along one of
the grid lines but we do know is that
each of its smaller rectangles right
each of these smaller tiles that make up
that large rectangle we know each one
has an integer width or an integer
height so each one of these is going to
cover equal areas of light and dark
squares so as we fill in the entire
rectangle by these smaller rectangles we
then end up that since each small
rectangle covers equal areas of light
and dark squares therefore the entire
large rectangle covers equal areas of
light and dark squares which means that
at least one of its sides is an integer
and therefore the rectangle R has at
least one side that's an integer length
did you figure it out thanks for
watching this video please subscribe to
my channel I make videos on math and
game theory you can catch me on my blog
mind your decisions which you can follow
on Facebook Google+ and patreon you can
catch me on social media at pressure
Walker and if you like this video please
check out my books their links in the
video description